Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
says Republicans might have to negotiate
with Democrats to pass a health care
reform bill McConnell says he wants to
keep working on both repealing and
replacing Obamacare but they may need to
work with Democrats on short-term
measures to stabilize insurance markets
that are on the verge of collapse in
many states Paula Reed is in our
Washington bureau with the latest Paula
good morning good morning repealing
Obamacare has been a signature issue for
Republicans for the past seven years but
as Congress returns to work on Monday
its proposed health care plan is on life
support the fate of the gops plan to
replace Obamacare lies with just a
handful of Republicans one of them is
Kansas senator Jerry Moran he's one of
the few senators holding town halls this
week he told constituents Thursday that
the current Senate bill misses the mark
on rural health care I have a member of
door and that Minority is Kansas Moran
is one of the 14 GOP senators who say
they have concerns about the current
bill Senate leaders can only afford to
lose two Republican votes the
Congressional Budget Office estimates
the bill would leave 22 million more
people uninsured by 2026 Senator Chuck
Grassley urged a group of voters Friday
not to worry about those numbers nothing
happens in regard to Medicaid until 2020
and then there's a gradual phase in of
the new program over the next five years
last week President Trump tweeted
support for a plan to immediately repeal
Obamacare and then work on a replacement
at a later date if an agreement cannot
be reached but Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell dismissed that option
and still wants a deal we have the salt
the current crisis and I think repealing
and then delaying the replacement
doesn't work
Senator McConnell acknowledges that if a
deal cannot be reached in the Senate
they may have to work with Democrats to
repair the existing market place him
Paula thank you